i know
and then
thank you
i just have to bring it up
my
um
you
okay
um
oh
so
food
um
is that what
i was getting thumbs i had no idea what
happened
we are being live streamed and so we're
going to ask that
myself
and other members of the committee
should they speak and when you speak
that we do so at live microphones so it
can be picked up over the live stream
that is going on right now we are here
on house official business this is
a duty of the house and before we begin
the input on the maps here i'm going to
ask that you rise and join me in a
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice
thank you everyone that is how the house
begins its work every day when we meet
here in session as i said we are here
being live streamed to receive comments
on the maps that have been posted online
there are two maps for every
district that
have been proposed by committee members
and we're here tonight to take input on
that mapping
if i didn't say so there is mask seating
to my left those would be in what we
refer to as sections four and five of
the hall
and
if you didn't know
if you look down at the little metal
plate
by your seat
and figure that you are in section one
two three four or five that is the code
to that strange license plate you see
around the state that says state
legislature
with a number one two three or five dash
and that dash leads to the seat number
and that metal plate tells you um what
seat you're in so there you go that's
the that's the code that you see driving
around the highway and frankly i think
it's there because none of us could
remember our seat from one session to
the other anyways
so that's how you find your seat and you
find each other
tonight so we know who would like to
speak in regards to the bills there is a
blue sheet outside for sign up i'm going
to ask that people come
to a microphone after i call them to
speak
we have
a number of people signed up
i expect to have more people signed up
after we go through these it is my
intent and to end this by 8 o'clock
so there isn't going to be a time limit
per se on speaking but if it gets to the
point in the evening where i'm worried
that not everybody is going to be able
to speak who wants to speak we might
start doing a time limit and generally
that's three minutes um three minutes is
actually what they tell us as
representatives is the limit for time
that you should be speaking in in order
to get your point across but of course
it's a lot different when you're talking
out to 400 people sitting here in the
hall
so with that i'd like to get started
we did have a session yesterday and this
is our second session this session
yesterday was during the day commencing
at ten o'clock and we are here on
wednesday november 10th commencing at
five and i started a little late and my
apologies for that
the first person signed up um is william
farm farnam from tamworth
and that name sounds very familiar to me
might have been we heard from somebody
yesterday
your wife
is the mic on yes yes it is welcome
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee uh i'm pleased to be here to
give my testimony
about
the maps
um the subject that i have is the
congressional district maps
competitive in elections
what does it produce
competition promotes more choice for the
voters
competition promotes more dialogue
between people with different points of
view
competition promotes better
understanding of the issues
competition promotes dialogue about
desired
outcomes when elections are competitive
the candidates must articulate
how they will represent all
of their constituents and i would like
to add here the elected official
once elected
all of the people of that district are
their constituents
not just the ones that solely voted for
them
competition ensures the best candidate
will be elected regardless of party
competition generates more voter turnout
thus better representation of all the
voters
what does
non-competitiveness in elections
what does it produce
less choice
a more shallow understanding of complex
issues
the candidates have no reason to explain
what they can do for all
of the constituents they will represent
they only need to appeal to one group
more extreme partisan candidates
no competition between different points
of view and no discussion of different
goals
less voter turnout
thus less representation and less
engagement with democracy
lower voter turnout can have
consequences on down ballot seats
no cooperation between the parties
no discussion of the goals and needs of
the constituents
moving 75 towns out of one congressional
district and placing them in another
is a major change
the proposed republican map
would move
365 thousand seven hundred and three
people
to a new district
the purpose of this change was stated by
republican party chair steve stepanek
who argued the party's newly won
majorities and the state house and
senate would give them the opportunity
to change the congressional maps in
their favor
snapnex said
be quote because of this we control
redistricting i can stand here today and
guarantee you that we will send a
conservative republican to washington dc
as a congressperson in 2022
to which i would say that fits the
definition of gerrymandering
in an interview with mur
in july sunu said he would veto
a redistricting proposal and i quote if
it doesn't pass the smell test and looks
like gerrymandering districts
if the republican proposed congressional
district map is put forward
the governor will have to hose his nose
or vetoing
thank you for your time and your work on
this very hard issue
and
may democracy go forward
madam chair griffin and other committee
members
my name is phil hatcher i've been a
resident of dover for the past 35 years
thank you for this opportunity to
provide input on your redistricting work
and thank you for providing a public
hearing in the evening
which will allow more people to
communicate directly with you on this
important topic
shifting to my testimony now
what is the point of having a
constitution
if you do not read it
at your november third work session
representative turcotte
when presenting the majority's proposed
new hampshire house map for coast county
stated that a map had no floaterials
and he saw no reason to add floaterials
i will give you a reason because the
constitution says that berlin with a
population of 9425
should have its own district
actually it does not say should
it says shall have its own district
so my question is
what is your reason for ignoring the new
hampshire constitution
or
perhaps the problem is not a failure to
read the constitution
perhaps the problem is misreading the
constitution
representative stephen smith when
questioned during the november fourth
work session about the majority's new
hampshire house map for cheshire county
offered a novel interpretation of the
new hampshire constitution's
requirements for redistricting the new
hampshire house
he said that walpole
with a population of
3633 was a little too large to warrant
its own district
i think you could hear the crowd that
they collectively murmur
say what
i believe the party of the majority is
the one that generally claims to hue to
the legal theory of original intent when
trying to interpret words and phrases
and statutes or constitutions
so let's check the legislative record
for cacr 41
which when passed in 2006 updated new
hampshire constitution to include the
text requiring eligible towns to receive
their own districts
crcr cacr 41 was sponsored by three
republicans
representative neal kirk
representative richard kennedy and
senator robert flanders when senator
flanders introduced it in the senate
he said quote
this crc this cacr provides that when a
town or ward has enough inhabitants to
equal
or exceed
the number required for one
representative seat
it shall have its own district
it's crystal clear
and the majority did not only ignore the
constitution and coast and chess here it
did this throughout the counties
in my county stratford
they chose to place dover ward 4 in a
district with madbury and lee
the district this district and a
district for durham were then combined
to form a floaterial with a single
representative
who will represent over 37 000 residents
this is crazy for several reasons
a large filterial first of all
then both dover ward 4 and lee have
sufficient population to require they be
given their own district
stratfor county residents also at the
county hearing the county listening
sessions
stated a clear preference
for the wards of rochester dover and
somersworth to be kept together and not
placed in districts with neighboring
towns
and this is totally unnecessary
but the minority map as well as the
mapathon map
keeping the dover and recharge through
rochester wards together while providing
more electrical towns with their own
districts
and does the majority map
while keeping the population deviation
below the 10 percent threshold
there's no reason
for what the majority is proposing for
strafford county
but ignoring
in 2011 perhaps you could get away with
claiming that your proposed map was the
best that could be done
but the public has gotten savvier and
the computational tools have gotten
better and more widely available
making that claim now
for these bogus maps is simply not going
to fly
either politically or legally
but ignoring the constitution is not
just ignoring some words on the page
it is ignoring the people who voted
overwhelmingly during the november
november 2006 election to approve cacr
41.
in fact 71 percent voted for crc cacr41
when you ignore the text inserted by
cacr41
you are ignoring those 71 percent
but when i stopped to think about it i
realized
that is really what this is all about
it's about rigging a system so that a
large majority of the voters can be
ignored
and the majority's proposal for the
congressional districts is more of the
same
they packing democratic leaning voters
in one district and packing the
republican leading voters in the other
district it has the striking result of
ignoring voters of both parties
republicans voting in the blues district
have no voice in the choice of their u.s
representative
democrats voting in the red district
also have no voice
all decisions are made in the primary
and the november election is meaningless
sound great
only if you are a leader in a party that
knows it cannot compete on a level
playing field and why was the state
gop's chair so excited at the prospect
of sending one more conservative to
congress
remember he made that statement in
january twenty twenty one
only a few weeks after many republicans
in congress voted to not accept
electoral votes cast for president biden
could it be that the new hampshire gop
is maneuvering to get one more gop vote
in congress to reject electoral votes
awarded by the popular
vote rigging his system one more time
ignoring the constitution one more time
to finally get to that holy grail of
removing the votes for president by
ordinary people
and replacing them with the votes of
republicans in a heavily gerrymandered
u.s congress
that would finish squaring the circle
wouldn't it
please reject the majorities on
constitutional new hampshire house maps
as well as their heavily gerrymandered
congressional map
let's not weaken any further these
pillars of our democracy
thank you for your attention
thank you mr hatch also signed up to
speak tonight is brandon lantham from
merrimack
thank you to the chair for your time
uh yes i'm brandon latham as we heard
i'm from merrimack
first i want to say if for some reason
someone can't hear me with the mask just
say so and i'll move away from the mask
section
we'll cross that bridge
um i'm from merrimack we can hear you
which means
three things
above all that we probably recognize if
anyone knows the town
means if i put a basketball down in my
driveway it'll end up in amherst before
it stops rolling
it means that my entire family lives in
nashua
and it means that i have spent my entire
district my entire life in congressional
district 1.
i'm here to speak about the
congressional map i hope you'll
recognize that the principles apply to
any maps that we're drawing
i mentioned nashua and amherst
we share conservation land with amherst
we share public water supplies with
nashua we also share commercial
districts with hollis
none of which are also in our
congressional district
i remember when i was about 13 years old
around the time i started high school in
nashua and being taught about our maps
and being taught about the voting
districts and thinking that this was
bizarre
and finding it deeply confusing that my
friends and family were voting for
different people and represented by
different people than i was
i didn't know the term communities of
interest at the time or common in the
principle of common interest at the time
i do now we all do
it is clear looking at the proposed
congressional map
that communities of interest was the
last priority
that the majority had in mind when
drawing the maps
i'm not here to advocate that it should
be the number one priority
but i think that it should be much
higher than dead last
if only for the reasons i mentioned the
confusion
the lack of representation
gerrymandered maps are anti-education
because
not only do they weaken the electoral
power of a school district that has been
divided
but they also make social studies
curriculum more difficult for children
who are rising to become voters
it never made sense to me then it
doesn't make sense to me now
in new hampshire we are proud of our
politics we're proud of this the most
representative legislative body in the
world right here in this chamber of our
classic new england-style town meetings
which
dozens of which and i'm sure someone in
the room has the number
voted this spring to
vote for independent fair maps without
partisan considerations
i know in my town i'm represented by
seven members of the majority
who are one of whom was on the town
council at the time
who appear to have ignored that message
from their voters
as we move forward and we try to
continue to be proud of our role as
politicos in new hampshire
we need to
prove that we are still that place that
exceptional place with an engaged
politic
that we have earned the sacred right to
our first in the nation primary
instead
if we move forward without a revised map
with the majorities map it will be an
embarrassment and a stain on that
reputation
if that doesn't convince anybody the
third thing i'd like to mention is
dollars and cents
um
having worked in outreach i did some
quick number running on what it would
take to inform the approximately three
hundred thousand new hampshire rights
whose congressional districts would be
changing
in a fair and equitable way that their
districts have been changing so that
they can be an informed voter
using the bar minimum the lowest that we
can do
base mailing
with
eddm targeting no specific targeting
we're talking about a minimum of 156 000
the alternative would be not doing a
voter education program
which seems
like a risk of even more expensive
lawsuits that i don't believe the state
should be taking
in conclusion significant revisions to
the majorities map would be
pro pro-education
policy in a more in a more abstract
sense pro new hampshire and working
toward our identity as proud of the
state that we're from
thank you very much
thank you
ellen farnham has signed up
you indicated this is to read a letter
miss farnam
it is thank you thank you very much um
i'm ellen farnham for tamworth and i'm
reading a letter of
a friend that lives in part of tamworth
known as jacaroa
a lot of folks that i know could not
attend this meeting in person
but are really watching this process
closely and are very concerned about
some of the redistricting challenges
this letter is written and when again
let me say it again
i'm reading a letter by john gotcha
this letter is written to make a case
for why the committee should not make
radical changes to the current
congressional districts in new hampshire
the proposed map that has been
distributed is the result of a plan that
is intended to create one district that
would stand a better chance of
consistently
electing republican candidates rather
than the pattern over the past decade
where district one is back fourth but
republican and democratic parties
while understanding that the current
majority party is motivated to promote
its interest in surging elect and
securing electoral wins it is a mistake
to move in this direction
the biggest mistake is that this change
would pretty much ensure the failure of
republicans to mount successful
campaigns in the new district to
discourage viable candidates from
running and promote further defections
from the party
and further should a candidate be
successful their chances of doing an
effective job and holding that seat
would be extremely unlikely given the
geographic sprawl of the proposed
district
secondly new hampshire has seen a huge
influx of new homeowners due to the
pandemic driven from the pandemic driven
flight from high population density
areas over the past two years the timing
of which means that it was not
represented in the 2020 census
the committee's proposed radical change
of the congressional districts could
well be a colossal misjudgment based
upon insufficient data
the republican party in new hampshire
promotes itself as the steady hand on
the wheel of the state government
i hope that the majority party on the
house special redistricting committee
continues this tradition with the
state's two congressional districts and
leaves them largely in their current
shape
and
not risk its long-term future by
alienating many current members of the
party
thank you very much for letting me read
the letter
thank you
representative ed butler has signed up
to speak
thank you
past representative ed butler oh the
honorable mr president thank you
um and i am happy to be back in this
hall
and again my name is ed butler i live in
hart's location
in the smallest town in new hampshire
and i'm the chair of the carroll county
democrats as well
thank you for holding this public
hearing and for the complex work that
you have
i attended the public hearing that you
held in carroll county
there were a variety of comments that
were made
none of which i have seen incorporated
into the maps that you are currently
considering
the most striking of the problems as
many of us in carroll county see it is
the very thin connection in the hills at
the top of sandwich and the bottom of
albany
where there is no road or telephone wire
or likely cell phone connection between
the two towns
but there is little
if
and there is a connection on the map of
course between the two towns but there
is little if any social or community
connection between the two towns
or between sandwich and the rest of the
towns that are connected through this
proposed district
sandwich has an affinity with tamworth
through various community and commercial
activities and with moultonborough
through 10 years of its current district
relationship
i hadn't seen before tonight the
proposed county commissioner districts
and i would just
encourage you to consider the minority
map
because even though it does
continue to have a sandwich
it connected
in that
very little
connection with albany it also connects
several other towns contiguous to it so
that there is a block that makes a great
deal more sense than leaving sandwich
hanging down
off the bottom of that
top district map
i appreciate that there has been an
independent effort being conducted by
open democracy through their mapathon
group
the last proposal by that group
regarding the house district seemed to
be best to me and to others who have
been paying closer attention to the
process than me
even though it seems to need
to need that unfortunate connection
between albany and sandwich
i hope that you are taking those
proposed non-partisan not
disservice to available electorate of
new hampshire
absolutely no one that i have heard
talking about this proposed map suggests
other than the fact that it defines what
party will win in each district
what then is the purpose of my vote
or the vote of any of those voting for
their congress person
i'm appalled
the proposed map for congressional
districts by the majority members of
this committee is appalling
thank you for allowing me to test
testify
thank you
gail laker phelps has signed up
it's i'm gail laker phelps and i'm from
the town of chichester
and thank you for having this public
hearing
new hampshire has a long history of
honoring
people's right to choose their
leadership
local as in our towns cities and
counties as well as for state and
national offices
people choose to reside here not only
for our scenic and lifestyle choices
and opportunities but for the long time
respect of individual choices through
our election process
our two
congressional districts as well as
counties and towns have traditionally
been competitive resulting in offices
swinging back and forth between the
parties as determined by the voters of
new hampshire
when towns counties and districts are
competitive the candidates from all
parties have to work
to attract the support of the voting
public
they must explain their values
and the goals they bring to that
particular office they are running for
such as the mayorship legislature
executive council
they have the chance to honestly debate
their opponents
this is the democratic process that has
held our state in good stead and has
made new hampshire a state where
fairness has been the rule and not the
exception
the redistricting map offered by the
majority would move 75 towns and over
375 residents into a different district
to openly lock in partisan control
thereby narrowing the public the voting
public's choices
other redistricting maps
offer
offered
that are offered solve the legal legally
required population changes with much
less disruption
and keep new hampshire's competitiveness
in play
one such map moves only one town
to the other district seems like a
simple solution
please reject
this
partisan majority map and support new
hampshire's strong historic record of a
fair electoral process
based on competition
and variety of candidates and party
offerings
thank you for your work your time and
hopefully your devotion to all of new
hampshire's voters
thank you thank you
dion lewis
thank you representative griffin and
i wanted to
just take a moment though
on the eve of veterans day and just
offer my thanks to anyone in the room
anyone listening
that's a veteran and
so thank you
to the committee
thank you for this opportunity to speak
thank you for listening
thank you for your service to the state
of new hampshire
last month i stood before you in
goffstown and spoke of my concern at
hearing the governor
needing to threaten to veto a map that
didn't pass the smell test
and now the republican congressional
district map that's been proposed has
it's been proposed with the most extreme
changes the state has seen in well over
a century
it's been noted that in 138 years
22 towns have moved from one district to
another
in this one republican map
75 towns awards have been moved
affecting 365 000 citizens
22 in over a century
75 proposed in the republican
congressional district map
it's staggering
how the republican map has been
gerrymandered
i've read your statements representative
lin
suggesting political considerations are
okay
since it's the responsibility of the
legislature to draw the maps
as confirmed by the courts
i'm here to say as a friend
remember the purpose of the legislature
is to serve our society
not the majority party
on this eve of veterans day i'm reminded
of some of the army values
loyalty
not to a political party
but to the constitution
selfless service
putting nation before self
integrity
do what's right
not just legally but morally as well
honor
living honorably with every choice
remember the highest military honor is
the medal of honor
but let's talk about power since that
seems to be a motivating force here in
this new gerrymandered map put forth by
the republican from my republican
friends
for the con congressional districts
for many of you republican democrat i
know i'm preaching to the choir when i
say those that drew up this map
have forgotten how to handle power
those of you that continue to conduct
yourselves honorably have a personal
power and i honor that
it's up to you to remind those that are
trying to grab power
that the reins of power are to be held
in an open hand
remember as soon as you try to grasp it
gather more of
it you lose yourself
power begins to control you
it's been said power tends to corrupt
i don't believe it's a given as long as
you can hold the reins of power in an
open hand
with a personal power greater than any
power society may confer upon you
but grasp it
hold on tight at all costs
and power controls you
you are honorable people
this is not an honorable map
it's not worth your soul
be courageous
in other army value
go home and tear up the republican
proposed map
be bold
swim against the current set in motion
by party
leaders
for those listening and not here i
have to put that in quotes
do what's right and show ah show us all
what's true leader what true leadership
looks like
thank you
bruce beer
good evening my name is bruce burke i'm
from the town of pittsfield
and uh
i want to thank you for your efforts and
i'm not going to be redundant i think
many of the points i was going to make
have been covered so
in respect for the work and the time i'm
just going to make one point
and that is that
yesterday the governor of this state
declined to run for the senate
that's despite the fact that people like
senator cruz
senator mcdonald mcconnell put
tremendous pressure on him
i think in the end
our governor realized it wasn't about
governor sununu
it was just about power
and i think in the end he chose to rise
above politics for this moment
and look to serve his state
rather than just to secure power
so many people have spoken before me
they've given you the statistics but
once again i would ask us to serve the
interests of the state
and not simply the interest of politics
thank you
alistana silva
good evening
thank you for listening to the concerns
of new hampshire citizens today
about maintaining a fair election
process
and for opening up last week's
redistricting meetings to the public
i hope you will give all these
testimonies
of concerned citizens the careful
consideration they deserve
my name is alice donna selva and i live
in concord in ward 7 in the merrimack
county
i am a relative newbie
to the realm of local politics and then
fine details over this of redistricting
when i entered the redistricting
committee last week
i naively expected that i would see my
representatives
working together to hammer out fair
districts
instead what i saw
was a room
that was divided
physically by political party
representative griffin
introduced the meeting with her
intention that two maps would be
presented at these hearings
presumably one republican and one
democrat
is this the best we can do
we pride ourselves on being first in the
nation
a state that other states aspire to
in terms of active
citizen involvement in the political
process
now more than ever
with the challenges we face as a state
and a nation
we need the benefit of diverse thinkers
putting their heads together to come up
with real solutions
instead this process has pandered to the
most
based divisive thinking
not only succumbing to the political
divide gripping our country
but exacerbating it
the process and the maps that were drawn
from it
as you've heard particularly the new
hampshire congressional district map
are a disappointment to say the least
one year ago
you and i and 814 090
new hampshire citizens
stood
in long lines in the cold to vote for
the candidates that we thought would
best move this country forward
not all of us were happy with the
results
but everyone i talked to
republicans democrats and independents
were proud to be standing together to
vote for the candidate that they thought
would best move this country forward
in the challenges we face today
and we rightfully trusted the new
hampshire election process
with all of the
conscientious and hardworking volunteers
the redistricting process that has led
to the new hampshire congressional
district map has been an abnegation of
the commitment this committee owes to
all of us who stood in those long cold
lines
does the republican drawn map that i
hold here
represent a map
that is visually
contiguous
does it look like a map
that has that has
been redrawn slowly with the
population changes in mind no
it has a striking resemblance to this
map
that was on the 538 website back in 2018
representing the most gerrymandered way
that you could you could create a map
for sure
while i hate to specify a
republican-drawn map and a democrat
drawn map this process has left me no
choice
so on the drawing of maps specific to my
county merrimack county
i support the democrat drawn out
it keeps conquered together
whereas the republican proposed map
divides it twice for no particular
reason
the democratic proposed map contains
only five violations of redistricting
rules as opposed to eight for the
republican map
in the true spirit of democracy
the democrats proposed map from
merrimack county
actually creates almost twice as many
competitive seats as the republican map
even at the at the cost of an extra seat
for them based on 2020 election data
thank you
roger blay
thank you very much
um my name is roger blow i live in ward
1 in manchester new hampshire i was born
in asheville new hampshire
and i married a manchester girl so i've
been living manchester for 51 years
i'm very proud of this
this committee it's nice that we can
voice what we
what we believe
i've always been a person that
my first primary thing is fairness
fairness if things are not fear it
irritates me immensely
and you know i was a little kid i liked
superman and lone range and all that and
i remember superman he fought for truth
justice and the american way this
republican map is not
just at all it's not fair it's not right
um i
i'm a liberal democrat
i worked hard to help
chris pappas win i love him i think he's
a great
person but if the republican would win
that's no problem but if it's fixed if
it's rigged you know what what good is
that that's not good at all i think we
should have an independent commission
the governor sununu had two chances
to set up one and he didn't
now
i'm a vietnam veteran and i was
fortunate enough to get my modern shots
at the va i had two of them
yet i still got covered
and uh fortunately it wasn't too bad but
i did lose my sense of smell for a
little while
i know governor sununu had covered so
maybe his smell test isn't right to know
that this republican
thing is is terrible it really really is
uh in 2010
uh the republicans were in charge and
they gerrymandered there as well and
they broke the state constitution by not
keeping towns and districts together
like they should have it went to the
state supreme court and they let it fly
so
legally you can probably get away with
this you probably can
but
it really upsets me i fought in vietnam
so that i can come to new hampshire
which i've always loved and always been
proud of and to see our fellow citizens
cheated
out of their votes yeah you know they
cut this country started because of lack
of representation from the british right
we were paying money for taxes we
weren't getting a representation if this
map republican maps goes through then
we're screwed and and it's just it would
embarrass me to be living in the state
with that kind of
uh representation thank you
thank you
mary beth raven
good evening distinguished committee
members
my name is mary beth raven and i'm a
32-year resident of new hampshire
i've lived in londonderry and for the
past 30 years in merrimack
and i'm here today not only for myself
but also to speak for the residents of
the town of merrimack
merrimack had a warrant article on their
town ballot this spring
asking for fair redistricting the
measure passed three to one
the voters of merrimack want fair
districts and by fair we mean
competitive as you all know competitive
districts result in elected officials
being more responsive to their
constituents
the congressional map that you have
proposed for our two congressional
districts however has major changes for
each district and does not make the two
districts competitive
the existing congressional districts had
a relatively balanced number of
registered republicans and democrats
in congressional district one it was 31
percent each and in congressional
district 2 it was 30 percent 32 percent
democrat and 29
republican
but this new proposal may makes each
district less balanced
specifically the proposal puts
congressional district 1 at 34 percent
republicans but only 28 percent
democrats while congressional district 2
is 35 percent democrat and 26 republican
i don't understand why you would want to
make unbalanced districts
your proposal has
cd1 having
over 1800 more people than cd2
we could make that more balanced too
and your proposal moves over 186 000
people from cd1 to cd2 and 178 000 from
cd2 to c1
what's the justification for moving 364
000 people
to different districts
i've been a registered democrat i've
been a registered republican i am
currently unaffiliated
i
and the 26 000 residents of merrimack
encourage you to go back to the drawing
board and create more balanced
congressional districts for the people
of new hampshire thank you
thank you
sue natassa
from rollinsford
come on down sorry
excuse me
um i'm sue anastasi and live in
rollinsford
proudly i am one of the three
supervisors
of the
of the checklist
for the town
learning the details of voting laws
election and keeping files up to date
throughout the year has been a rewarding
experience
as a member of the new hampshire legal
union voters i have learned more details
of voting rights and fully support the
league's mission
empowering voters and defending
democracy
in both situations i can say
i know and recognize nonpartisanship
not being biased or partisan
especially toward any political group
rollinsford has and has proposed to keep
four
represent state representatives
for the population of 2597.
if only looking at rollinsford i can't
agree but it's important to understand
the larger picture
for strafford county
and that is where four representatives
are acceptable
once again looking at the larger picture
in this time for the state's
congressional redrawn maps it is packed
gerrymandered
or
a prime case where
legislators
pick their voters
where it should be
that voters choose their representatives
this committee is smarter than that
proposed congressional map
there is more work for you all to do
you have all done work and traveling to
each county
listening to an array of thoughts for
the voters
towns and counties
in order to represent
correctly
the voters your constituents elect you
again not the other way around
all granite staters are entitled to fair
voting districts
thank you for your time
but more of your work is necessary
thank you
kevin coyle from portsmouth
oh is this the written right
good evening representative griffin and
members of the committee and a special
thank you to the audience all of whom
took the time out tonight to come and
speak to you i hope that you'll listen
i want to talk about
the rockingham county redistricting
i am a former rockingham county
commissioner i currently live in
portsmouth but prior to that for 40
years i lived in derry
and represented nine towns as the
district three rockingham county
commissioner for eight years
i looked at the map that has been
redrawn
and i was puzzled by it
because it made no sense to me
why they would change
the districts you're moving 175
000 people
out of the district that they have
currently been in and have been in for
over 20 years
into a new district
and i can't think of a reason
why you would do that the districts are
not significantly different size wise by
moving one town you could have made them
almost identical in size that being in
the town of newfields
into district one
but
it did not make any sense to me why the
republican maps made such a radical
change
and the democrat maps made no change
whatsoever
i can tell you that for the last 30
years
there has been
without question
every member of the county commission
was republicans
until
when one democrat who happens to be my
wife
became a county commissioner
and because of that
we have new maps
which make no sense are going to cause
serious issues for
who becomes who has the next
four-year term who currently has the
four-year term now
it would it just makes no sense and i've
spoken to
both former and current county
commissioners and none of them support
this map and i would respectfully ask
you to go back to the drawing board and
leave the maps as they currently exist
and
as a republican i support the democratic
maps thank you
thank you
louise spencer
hi thank you my name is louise spencer
from concord new hampshire and i thank
you for the opportunity to
give my testimony tonight
and i would like to first and foremost
thank
every member of this committee i know
you have spent many hours and given
much of your time and hard work
to this process
and i do sincerely appreciate that
i also want to thank the minority here
on the committee
for the thoughtful maps that you've
presented
what i particularly appreciated in
hearings when you presented the maps
was that you gave your reasons for the
changes that you've made
and i found that to be very
very helpful
and i appreciate that
i'm not going to apologize for being
redundant
for repeating things that are being said
by other people or that have been said
at other hearings
because
we need you to listen
we need you to hear what we're saying
and it's the reason that we're saying it
over
and over and over again
the people of new hampshire
the people of the granite state want
fair
non-partisan
maps
it's as simple
as that
and it is a goal that can be
accomplished
we know that it can be done
it just takes the political will
to do it
and i'm asking this committee to dig
deep every member
and to find that political will
as a conquered resident i currently live
in a ward that is combined with an
adjacent town
and with hopkinton i'm in ward 5.
it doesn't
make sense to me that that's
my current district
although i love my reps i don't think
you can find
three public servants that
um
that i could be more proud of to to call
my representatives
i note that under the majority maps
this district is maintained in addition
ward 7 of concord is put with
beau
the communities of interest
don't appear to have been considered
we don't share schools we don't share
fire and police our demographic profiles
are very different
the demands on our social services are
different indeed our very structures of
government are different
our communities of interest lie
elsewhere and for ward 5 and ward 7 in
concord
those interests lie with the city of
concord and this is true for cities
throughout the state the communities of
interest lie with other wards
within their cities
and cities deserve to have their
interests represented at the state house
without their their votes being deluded
but we've heard very little about
communities of interest from the
majority in fact we've heard very little
about what criteria other than the most
basic constitutional requirements
that have been used to draw their maps
perhaps if we had heard more perhaps if
we had been told
these maps might make more sense to us
but without that knowledge
we really have no alternative but to
assume
that politics is the driving force
behind these maps
in fact we heard from representative
lynn
that redistricting of course
plays a consideration in the mix i don't
think we can doubt that
we're human after all
but it does not need nor should it be
the driving factor
these maps go against
everything the public has repeatedly
asked
our legislature to do
i repeat
people want an end to gerrymandering
they want an end to politics being more
important than our civic life and our
body politic and our ability to relate
and connect to one another
we want to heal this nation
we want to come together
and one of the ways that we do that is
by having fair maps that require
candidates to go out and earn their
votes by talking to all
of the voters
and opening dialogue with all of the
voters
that's what i sincerely want
i'm a democrat i don't deny it i'm a
liberal democrat
but i want to be talking to my
republican
neighbors
i want their voices represented and
these majority maps
are unfair
and they leave out half
of the state of new hampshire
particularly in the congressional maps
we are all the people
republicans independents
and we deserve better representation
than what these maps are giving us from
the majority thank you
thank you
emily olson from goffstown
sorry with the tables up here it's a
little hard to get around
dear committee and fellow constituents
i'd first like to thank the committee
for allowing the public to make use of
article 32 of the new hampshire
constitution
giving us a chance to give testimony
after the proposed maps were published
i personally would like to thank you for
listening to us
during the previous round of testimony
it is hardening to know our requests are
being heard
and i would also like to thank my fellow
new hampshire residents for braving the
pandemic and coming out tonight to give
testimony for and against each of the
maps
my name is emily olson i'm here on
behalf of myself and my family
i've been a resident of goffstown
my whole life and feel very strongly
about shaping the future of the granite
state
in a way that will see us succeed now
and long into the future
i was present at the previous public
testimony at goffstown high school a few
weeks ago you might remember a bit of a
fiery testimony then
i am honored albeit a little nervous
to be here with you tonight
my fellow new hampshire citizens have
done a marvelous job of going over the
numbers so i would like to give a more
personal angle specifically
i would like to go over two points
parity and prospects
for parity
well i personally identify more with
titles and after being an independent
voter for the
majority of my adult life
i understand that what is good for me
may not be good for the rest of new
hampshire
i understand that democracy thrives on a
healthy and fair competition
and i understand that both sides of the
aisle have tried to upset this fair
competition by gerrymandering districts
all over the country
when redistricting is done in a manner
that breaks up seven out of the ten
counties and unfairly distributes seats
healthy competition is lost
when healthy competition is lost and
seats are considered safe for either
party public servants can safely assume
that they do not need to listen to the
people they serve or even respond to
their constituents because they are not
worried about losing their seat
once this happens democracy breaks down
a process that we can already see
happening in our country and in our
state today
i personally love being a part of a
swing state a toss-up state like i said
i've been a registered independent for
the most of my life
i love going out and talking to
democrats and republicans and i voted
for both sides of the aisle previously
it means that the voters are being heard
and our representatives must earn our
vote
specifically looking at new hampshire's
process of drawing the registry
redistricting maps this year
it is blatantly obvious that parity has
been left out of the process from the
beginning
some people have already mentioned
steven stefanik's
quotes from earlier this year in january
but i would like to reiterate
that this process should be a
non-partisan process of drawing
districts that will impact the
legislative makeup of our state for
years to come
a process that should be independent of
politics
representative robert lynn of wyndham
you have revealed otherwise
last week in response thank you just be
sure that you're you are speaking to the
entire community not any one individual
thank you i apologize thank you thank
you
so for the whole committee okay
this is not a political process it
should not be a political process
we are choosing you
please show me in the new hampshire
constitution or even the u.s
constitution where it says that you are
allowed to choose
who represents us
should not be a political process
we as your constituents have been asking
for parody and redistricting maps for
decades
it is your duty to convince us that you
are the best candidates for the job
representing us and serving our needs
when we go to the ballot
now talking about future prospects
myself personally
if the proposed majority congressional
map
will dictate the next 10 years of my
life and my future family's life
i'm a little
nervous while you only have to be
concerned about if your party is going
to win the elections of the next decade
i have to worry about if my school
district my children's school district
is going to have enough funding for my
children to be sufficiently nurtured and
cared for
because we do not have enough money in
the state
i have to worry about if the effects of
climate change are going to negatively
impact my life and my family's
well-being because we are not prepared
for something we see coming straight for
us
i have to worry about the church being
allowed to dictate my health and
personal decisions in the state where we
pride ourselves on living for your dying
i have to worry about if i lose my job
and need help to feed my family will my
state support me until i can get back on
my feet
i have to worry about if my elected
officials who are supposed to serve me
and the rest of new hampshire are going
to pass legislation that we need that
will help us grow and succeed
or if we are going down the rabbit hole
of the race to the bottom except this
time the bottom of democracy and morals
i have to worry about the next decade
because this year's redistricting
process has been a partisan
bastardization of the democratic process
to the majority committee members we are
not incompetent we see what you are
doing you do not have to look closely to
see that you are cheating your way to an
elected position to a guaranteed seat
from cd1
to the committee as a whole we have come
to you with open arms asking for you to
let us help with this process that we
care so deeply about we offered
non-partisan non-biased technology and
platforms to come to a fair non-partisan
redistricting pro
plan that will represent new hampshire
as we are
haven't really delivered
i don't i'm not a fan of either map but
the majority map
breaking the constitution
where are we at why are we here
at this point i feel incredibly
disenfranchised as a voter and as an
active member of the state
i only hope the majority members of this
committee can realize a lack of
equitable
and fair representation of this
redistricting process and redress your
actions before these maps are made law
i urge you to reconsider seriously the
maps proposed by open democracy the maps
that we have so clearly stated that we
want
thank you for your time and your
consideration and please take into
consideration my future here
thank you
also signed up to speak is
kirsten higger from mont vernon
hello thank you for letting me speak
tonight uh my name is kirsten hugger
yeah you need to
kirsten hugger
thanks we want to make sure that the
video feed picks up on it okay thank you
so
last summer
as most people probably in this room
probably know governor sununu vetoed a
bill
to create an independent redistricting
commission
he said in his veto and i quote new
hampshire
has a redistricting process that is fair
representative
and accountable to its voters he also
said gerrymandering in the state is rare
so imagine my dismay
when the very first round of maps that
came out
following his
veto were so obviously gerrymandered
i'm gonna say three points to
gerrymandering that have already been
said here tonight but i think that
they're worth reiterating number one
gerrymandering aggravates partisan
divide
most that when you have a gerrymandered
district the most important election
becomes the primary with the main
election being secondary
this encourages
politicians to drift to extremes and
worsens the partisanship in our state
number two
competition among political candidates
ensures that new hampshire voter
concerns are being heard and addressed
if there's no threat of losing a seat
there is no incentive to respond to
voters
and number three gerrymandering is
anti-democratic
if results are nearly predicted people
become discouraged they have less
incentive to vote and they have less
incentive to participate because they'll
feel their vote is being wasted
new hampshire voters should choose their
representatives not the other way around
and new hampshire voices deserve to not
be silenced by gerrymandering thank you
for your time
thank you
jules good
before i get to the meat of my testimony
i want to acknowledge the many granite
staters who due to disability lack of
transportation options or job
responsibilities do not have the
opportunity to make oral testimony due
to the lack of any remote testimony
option for this session
i thank you for providing the
opportunity for input but providing it
in such a limited context when we saw
that it is possible for remote testimony
to happen is both disappointing and a
giant step backwards for the
accessibility of our democracy
we all know pages of written testimony
in your committee inbox just don't quite
pack the same punch as oral testimony
my name is jules good and i'm the ward 4
select person in somersworth new
hampshire as an election official and
someone passionate about equal access to
voting i'm appalled by the proposed
majority congressional map
i want to start by saying that while i'm
obviously a human with my own political
views i am here in my capacity as an
advocate for equal voting rights for
everyone regardless of their party
affiliation
when districts are manipulated to create
guaranteed wins for one party
constituents in those districts lose
their freedom of choice and elected
officials lose incentive to be
accountable for their decisions in
office
with no competition in a district
candidates of the majority party will be
less likely to actively listen to their
constituents needs because they no
longer feel that they have to win them
over
if you were an nba basketball star
playing one-on-one against a middle
school kid would you practice and train
as hard as you would if you knew you
were playing another nba athlete no
you'd probably feel safe and slack off
this means that a rigged map hurts
voters in both parties because the value
of a win is diminished for the majority
and the likelihood of earning a win is
significantly lowered for the minority
how am i as an election official
supposed to get your tituans excited
about voting and participating in
democracy if they are effectively
betting on a rigged game
the proposed majority map is
disrespectful to the intelligence and
autonomy of voters in both parties and
we should not implement it
thank you
olivia zinke
good evening members of the committee
and madame chairwoman
first i want to thank the committee for
taking the time to listen
to voters at the public input sessions
but also tonight i hope you will take
the input you've heard and readjust the
plans
um i also thank you both for keeping the
city of franklin together
instead of dividing our awards
our award lines will need to be adjusted
but in the charter
and a charter change by voters at our
next municipal elections our current
wards are 526 people different so it
will have to be adjusted i know this
committee made an assumption that ward
lines would be
as close to perfect as they can
equal wards in our city
would be hard because the river divides
one of our ward and to cross the river
and to change that i think ward one will
always keep a population which it
currently has of three thousand one and
one people
i think it's also important when we look
at the city ward lines that are impacted
by all of these
that many cities aren't lucky like the
city of franklin the city of claremont
is joined with croydon the city of
rochester ward 5 is joined with milton
the city of manchester gets less
representation than it deserves it
should have 34 representation not less
numbers than that
dover has joined
ward 4 with
durham lee and madbury
i think the summersworth one combined
with rollinsford is unavoidable because
of geography
has to be combined with another but
laconia ward six
in one plan joined with gilford or
gilmington or in another plan joined
with belmont or
or
gilmington um
portsmouth ward one is is divided with
newington and newcastle keane's ward two
and three have
when one plan with all alstead
marlow stoddard and sullivan
or in another plan combined with
um
marlboro and you've heard about concord
ward 4 with bo in concord ward 5 with
hopkinton but i do think it's really
important that this committee looks at
the maps and tries to keep the integrity
of cities together
as much as it possibly can and i
understand the complexities with some
cities having to amend their
charters the city of claremont will
amend their charter in two years as well
as somersworth so that will be done like
the city of franklin after this
committee has done their work and so
those award lines will be adjusted
as somersworth adjusted them
in
2013 in their last charter change
so i think that that as you sort of keep
in mind city charter processes please
keep in mind in keeping the cities
intact in in any way you possibly can
thank you
bill maddox
from amherst
hi my name is william maddox i live in
amherst and i want to thank the house
redistricting committee for holding this
hearing and the previous hearings around
the state
i want to point out it's
fortunate that those with serious health
concerns can't attend these meetings
remotely and be able to speak
we're in the middle of a
very serious
epidemic a very serious health crisis
pendant epidemic is raging more than 30
people are dying each week in this state
and it's just common sense that access
be made by all means possible in this
very extraordinary situation
i want to remind you that amherst was
among 74 towns representing 560
868 granite staters who voted in favor
of a fair redistricting process in town
or city elections last spring
in fact
in amherst the warned article passed by
almost three to one margin
i expect it to not been the worst part
of a hundred year pandemic that count
would have been far higher
people are sick and tired of unfair maps
and gerrymandering but this apparently
does not matter to some members of this
committee
who essentially ignored the will of 561
thousand voters
a fair registering redistricting process
is important to me
so that republicans and democrats can
have a level playing field in our
elections
but instead you have chosen to
gerrymander our two congressional
districts in the most radical change in
140 years
if i were a republican in house district
2 it'd be clear to me that my own party
disenfranchised
my ability to vote on congressional
representation in a meaningful way
i don't know what's going on with the
new hampshire republican party
it seems the thrill of the insurrection
in january
where we almost lost our nation's
capital
and the major science denial around
stopping a deadly virus
has possibly altered your thinking and
rendered you incapable of putting your
own narrow interests above the will of
the people and what is best for healthy
and vibrant democracy
let this be an important civics lesson
for students who are trying to
understand how democracy works
and how it is undermined
shame on you
gerrymandering is unpatriotic
it's unamerican
and gerrymandering is cheering
thank you
the honorable bob perry
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm happy to be here again in
this chamber i wish it were under a
different circumstances
arise to speak against your proposed
congressional map by which you seemingly
stand firm
comparing the map with those which
became law over the last 149 years
reveals more than a bizarre departure
it reveals a flagrant plan to reduce the
value and political of influence
political influence of voters of your
own party
in order to guarantee a democrat cannot
win in congressional district one
you have been reminded of the following
quote by republican party chair steven
stepanek but it must be hurt again for
its
audacity quote because of this
republican majority
we control
redistricting
i can stand here today and guarantee
that you will send a conservative that
we will send a conservative republican
to washington d.c as a congressperson in
2022 end quote
i remind you and the r shucks both
parties are guilty crowd
that new hampshire democrats have never
produced gerrymandered resisting maps
because they have never been the party
in power
when our constitutions required
redistricting
this map is a replication of the
infamous dragon shaped executive council
district number two map
republicans passed into law in 2012
which on a continuum sacrificed the
value of republican votes in order to
create republican safe districts
elsewhere in the state
governor sununu called this sprawling
district quote weird end quote
as if not gerrymandered
as if of no consequence playing on the
ignorance of voters on this topic
despite the conservative a misnomer
supreme court of the united states
acquiescence in this undemocratic
endeavor of partisan gerrymandering
you have the opportunity to do the right
thing by voters and democracy by simply
moving one town
hampstead
from district 1 to district 2
narrowing the math m-a-t-h
to precisely 50 people
the governor has publicly stated he
would not all passage into law any map
that doesn't pass the smell test
governor sununu if you're listening
reject this map
it does not pass the smell test
the straight face test or any other
objective assessment of the one person
one vote principle of fairness and
equity
thank you
roger mcinaudis
sorry about that with the name
thank you
good evening and thank you for allowing
us to speak this evening
um
i'm speaking in opposition to the
republican redistrict redistricting
proposal
that you're currently proposing
this undemocratic proposal takes a swing
district which should be the goal of any
redistricting
in order to allow
people a realistic chance to elect the
best candidate and it turns it into a
republican stronghold
this is this is nothing short of an
abuse of power and an attack on our
democracy
redistricting should not diminish the
belief that an individual's vote matters
that the voting process process isn't an
exercise in futility
a fair redistricting when necessary
should hold promise for candidates for
from any party to throw their hats into
the political ring
with a realistic possibility of winning
the support of the majority on election
day
something i don't see happening with the
republican plan
i'm also saddened to see our democracy
slipping away
driven by politicians more interested in
a political party and power
rather than in the representation of the
people
and rather than in fairness the american
ideals and the integrity of our
democracy
my hope is that there will be there will
emerge a final redistricting proposal
that looks at fair representation just
distribution of population geography
and balance
not unlike the democratic proposal
furthermore
with this partisan proposal it has
become clear that the job of defining
congressional districts should no longer
be in the hands of a single party
rather it should be in the hands of an
independent committee
but first
this redistricting proposal should be
scrapped in favor of one that better
serves all new hampshire voters in their
selection of its representatives
one where our democracy will flourish
thank you very much
thank you
matthew gerding
hi
thank you for having me today and thank
you for being here
my name is matthew gerding i am a city
councilor in somersworth i am here today
to strongly request that the committee
vote no
on the federal congressional district
maps being proposed by the republican
majority
not only would the approval of these
congressional district maps be the most
dramatic change ever made to the new
hampshire congressional districts but
their passage would be an insult to me
in the city which i
represent under the majority's proposed
maps somersworth along with a number of
other communities would for the first
time ever be shifted from congressional
district 1 to congressional district 2
in what appears to be an attempt to
build a congressional district that is
highly democratic leaning
and another that is highly republican
leaning
this is evident by the blatantly
partisan choices of the communities that
were shifted between districts there was
no conceivable regard for shared
location demographics or history
counties were broken apart including my
own of stratford county
neighbors were divided and school
districts were separated in this process
i understand that lines must be drawn
somewhere as we all do but to utilize a
one-town wide sliver to connect
democratic-leaning communities along the
easterly border of the state to the
remainder of the congressional district
2 seems a bit suspect to me
to be perfectly clear it seems that the
only concern when these maps were made
were the political makeups of these
communities i reference
in what world do residents of
somersworth
keen
all the way in the western corner of the
state and pittsburgh new hampshire at
the very top of our state share the same
demographic values and needs
though i may not know how or why this
committee felt that it could blatantly
gerrymander these maps what i do know
for certain is that somersworth and its
residents do not appreciate being used
as a pawn in some larger political power
grab by republicans
this shift in congressional districts
would work to silence my constituents by
politicians who likely don't care much
about somersworth
they care about their own scramble for
power i certainly hope that it is not
the case
and certainly not the case that party
leaders are so hungry for power that
party ideology would trump the needs of
towns cities school districts and most
importantly the people of new hampshire
this is not the new hampshire i thought
i lived in and i hope it has not been
forgotten who government serves
i would be embarrassed to see these
majority maps passed
for new hampshire to steep to the low
point of gerrymandering and electing
rigging
i think that we are better than this and
i think that you are better than this
thank you for your time
thank you
lucas meyer
good evening chairwoman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak tonight i know a lot of folks
during the public hearing process last
month
spoke very clearly to the need for this
so thank you
for the opportunity and i'm grateful for
each and every member's
service to our state although this
process is pushing that to the brink
uh we did not have to be here
for the past three years there have been
bipartisan efforts to introduce an
advisory
independent redistricting commission
which would have at least allowed
for
[Music]
a more perfect process nothing is ever
perfect but allowing for
independents republicans and democrats
to come together to draw a map but those
maps were rejected excuse me that
process was rejected
opponents some of which
sit on this committee
said why would we allow non-elected
granite staters to make decisions when
we
are elected by the people
how do you remain accountable to the
people when you as politicians go behind
closed doors and decide who those voters
are
my friends and family understand that i
follow these processes very closely
so since chairman stepanek's comments
back in january
they would ask me how bad will it be
luke
how bad will these maps be
they're worse than i could have imagined
and you don't have to take my word for
it
acclaimed new hampshire professor dante
scala worked with a research assistant
to try and draw what he characterized as
the most republican maps possible and he
fell short
of this committee's work
these maps present a very clear threat
and you can hear in the testimony from
my fellow granite staters that they
understand this threat they feel it to
their core it makes them emotional it
makes me emotional
because it is a threat
to the bedrock of our democracy free and
fair elections
there are members of this committee
who will say
and support
anti-voter bills under the guise of
election integrity
i can think of no greater tyranny
i can think of no greater example of
undermining the integrity of our
elections
of our voters
than these rigged maps
please
the message is clear the message is
redundant reject these maps
i'm not saying you have to adopt the
democrats proposal but have some common
sense
because what these maps represent
is the threat that our state will lose
that ability to find consensus
to find common sense and to bring people
together
so i implore i beg
reconsider these maps go back to the
drawing board and produce something
everyone in this room can be proud of
thank you
susan richman
thank you for the opportunity to give
testimony and and yes thank you for
the countless hours that you put into
this um
at the listening sessions that i
attended the most frequent request i
heard was that towns meeting the
population requirement be guaranteed
their unique representative as
stipulated in the new hampshire
constitution
with the house of representatives that
numbers 400 it seems we should be able
to achieve the goal of our original
founders that
at least as close as possible each
minute municipality should have its own
representative
the open democracy mapathon team's
analysis by county showed how many
violations each set of maps had and a
violation meant a town not getting its
constitutionally
guaranteed or hoped for
uh independent
uh representative so i'm not gonna go
through the whole table here which will
be in the testimony i'm gonna put on
your website but um
for example belknap the majority map
eight violations so eight towns that
don't have a representative that isn't
that would have been entitled to it but
on the mapathon map five towns so that's
a difference of three
more striking
cheshire county
majority map
seven violations mapathon map four
difference of three so
going down and adding those columns
there are
more total
violations
in the majority maps than the mapathon
maps
keeping with the maps that have just
that five percent deviation if you go to
the 15 percent deviation there's
actually a difference of 22 towns so
that's um
that's about a third of the violations
could have been reduced by coming up
with a different map in this case the
mapathon map so i'm not saying
precisely that's the map to use but it
shows at least that it can be done that
we do not need to
disenfranchise
unconstitutionally
61 towns from having their own
representative
and i worry also that that then becomes
perhaps a matter for litigation if the
maps should be adopted
thank you for allowing my testimony
thank you diane mccain the khan
thank you i'm from durham new hampshire
and i wanted to play a little game
perhaps we could call it jeopardy
uh what do you call it when uh
a map that appears
seems to confer
advantages to those who make the map
what do you call it
when the map manipulates and protects
certain party lines
what do you call it
when the map decreases one group's
voting strength
or
oh i'm so sorry just get a little closer
or reduces values of the votes in an
isolated way
what do we call it when politicians pick
the voters versus the voters picking the
politicians
what do we call it when people are
disenfranchised
and their votes have less impact
what do we call it when one party takes
unfair political advantage
what do we call it when the districts
are rigged and maps are creating
uh
an entrenchment of a majority party
i think we know what we call it we call
it gerrymandering thank you
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative mary harkin phillips
good evening thank you for taking my
testimony
my name is mary hacken phillips and i'm
a hanover resident and representative of
grafton county district 12 serving
hanover and lyme
i'm also an attorney practicing in
concord and
i hold a master's degree in political
science
i wanted to thank you
all for the public comment periods
previous to tonight as well as for this
evening
and thank participants in the room and
for those who submitted
testimony online do you want to get a
little closer to the mic also maybe lift
it up a little bit or
yeah just so you're
speaking a little closer to it thank you
um
participating in democracy is so
important so participation in the
process up to this point
just worthy of a little more praise
um
gosh
i'm speaking tonight
to you tonight in my capacity as a
representative first as your colleague
but then again as a lawyer second
gosh i have a duty to inform you as the
representative for hanover and lyme that
hanover warrant article
number 27
as a resolution in our town meeting for
successfully passed
states that my community demands that
this process result in a fair and
effective representation of new
hampshire voters
and that independent redistricting
commission should draw these maps in a
way that does not rely on partisan data
like election results
party registration or favor political
party candidates or candidates
obviously we've missed that independent
process so we're here today
second i have a duty to inform you as a
lawyer and as your colleague
you are in trouble
good thing you're sitting down
tell the ag's office to get their staff
attorneys ready because you guys are
going to be in for a litigation fight
this
i mean let's let's just face it this
proposal is extreme
if it's adopted in its current form it's
proposed by the majority of this
committee you're
ripe for litigation and you're giving
lots of ammunition to the opposition
first of all the process
your pre-hearing notice process lacked
enough time for people to adequately
participate
uh it also
lacked access there are plenty of folks
who could not participate because there
was no remote option
and you're denying those who cannot be
there because of elder care child care
health care
work arrangements to participate
meaningfully
you drop the ball
now that's just the pre-hearing concerns
now we're talking about post-hearing
concerns
i've yet to see an authentic
transparency of your map drawing process
from the majority
i implore you to publish
the gis shape files
sought by constituents to see the level
of granularity needed to evaluate your
maps
i'm also concerned about
you know the issue of a report detailing
what you've learned at those public
hearings
whether or not you took that information
into consideration and drawing your maps
and if you didn't take it into
consideration why that did not happen
the public has a right to know the
decision-making process that leads us up
to this
proposed map
and you know
they also deserve to know why you're
ignoring the will of the people
gosh you're ripe for litigation because
of your methodology as well these maps
reveal that the committee majority was
unable to avoid the dangerous abuses
that were so enticing when drawing these
new lines
simply put
these maps and in particular the
congressional maps
that are proposed are packed and cracked
your large cities and towns are packed
together your small communities are
cracked apart
gosh you're robbing all of these
constituents a real chance at real
representation
you're ripe for litigation because it's
a severe breach
of following legal statutory
statewide political precedent and more
daniel webster said
the right to choose a representative is
every man's portion of sovereign power
you may have heard that in the burling
versus speaker of the house case from
our supreme court in 2002.
gosh experts have already stated their
astonishment with these maps
you've got experts on the record before
the maps are published telling you
warning you this is a bad idea
you know we're destroying
any reflection of polling that's out in
the public realm or any political public
opinion
you have been given clear warning that
people are demanding an independent fair
map and a good process and you're
dropping the ball
part two articles nine and eleven of our
new hampshire constitution speak to the
you know
serious of your job at task and the
rules that guide you in this
you know particularly that each 344
people should result in a seat for a
town or multi-municipal
municipal area across the state so that
each person's vote has equal weight
you're missing it
obviously we're not creating competitive
congressional districts with these maps
despite the 150 years of political
tradition in our state
and despite the de minimis population
shifts that have resulted from the
census data
gosh you're running counter to the
supreme court of the united states and
the 1965 reynolds versus sims case which
stood for the guiding principle one
person one vote
not to mention the equal protection
clause
gosh you guys
you're going to have all sorts of claims
about
minority discrimination as a result of
these congressional maps for the sec
like the southern side of the state
you're going to be in trouble there
gosh all right well so we're looking at
a lot of concerns a lot of them
you are my client
i'd tell you you need to reassess your
position
the consequences of gerrymandering are
going to propose irreparable harmonic
communities if they're enacted this way
it's going to divide our political
parties by furthering
you know favoring one party
in power at the expense of the minority
worse yet it's going to give one party a
majority in the state house or a seat in
congress despite only winning a minority
of the votes
politicians again are picking their
voters
not the other way around this is
undemocratic and deeply unpatriotic
ask yourself
what is the long-term political
consequence for your party for our state
for the voters
if these maps are enacted into law
they're hurting our neighbors
their voting rights by invalidating
their votes they're hurting our children
in their schools
and they're disproportionately affecting
people of color in this state
it's going to split school districts
traffic flows fire departments
communities of interest and the list
goes on
it's a warning
i'm here to warn you
democratic minority maps are reasonable
they're competitive
they honor our state's tradition
our constitution and our laws
as well as compliance they also comply
with the supreme court of our united
states as well as the constitution of
the united states
if you don't adopt the minority maps
and you move to enact these majority
maps
attention and litigation will fall upon
the state of new hampshire
do not let new hampshire become the next
battleground in courts over
gerrymandering don't let us become the
next south carolina texas
ohio
virginia
various fair maps organizations like the
las law group
and the aclu
will follow they will be ready and they
will litigate
it's a scandal it will be
not only will you lead this state
out into drawn litigate drown out with
drawn out litigation through extraneous
costs born
strictly by the taxpayers burden
it's also going to attract adverse media
coverage
yet again it will be another extreme
political issue in the national media
showing that the granite state
because of our current leadership
is extreme
will this extreme power grab be the
straw that finally breaks the camel's
back
causing our beloved electorate the
time-honored tradition of voting
at the first in the nation primary
this will have dire consequences to our
citizens if we lose it
ask yourself if you want to be
responsible for this ultimate decision
you will be held accountable if so by
voters here in the granite state
most important i have a question for
your committee
at a time when public confidence in
government is at an all-time low if this
committee creates a pre-ordained outcome
under new hampshire gop leadership
to deprive the voters of any meaningful
influence in the next election with
these proposed majority maps
are you the committee prepared to own
the decision
to rob these americans of their most
fundamental way of participating in our
democracy
this will have severe consequences for
our government our institutions and our
society
the very american experiment itself is
at stake
representative i'm going to need to ask
you to wrap it up
thank you political theorist alexis de
tocqueville always thought that america
was making a big mistake by allowing the
everyday jefferson yeoman
you know the farmer the common man
to vote
this frenchman political elitist
missed it but our founding fathers
understood better
that everyday americans had the ability
to fill their civic duties and to vote
to determine who we are and what we will
be what common good we will achieve
heed our founding fathers calls
honor free and fair elections and do not
put yourself in a position for the
potential litigation that will follow
and against our founding fathers wishes
thank you very much for your time
thank you for coming again to a session
also signed up to speak is nicholas
macri
hello
hello members of the committee thank you
for hearing our testimony today
my name is nicholas macri and i'm a
resident of hanover and a student and
employee of dartmouth college
as you decide the new district
boundaries for our state's congressional
districts i implore you to reject the
committee majority's proposed districts
which are gerrymandered that seeks to
remove democracy from the selection of
new hampshire's representatives in
congress
i will uh admit that i showed up to this
hearing five minutes late because there
is no remote option
i do not have a car i had to arrange
transportation to concord
um so maybe i missed it but i have not
heard a single person in this hearing
support your majorities maps
not a single person
everybody here has been saying the exact
same thing you know what i'm going to
say
you know what everybody after me is
going to say
this has a very strong feeling of
procedural democracy
we're all standing here we're all
begging you to not do this
to allow us to have competitive
elections
for the past decade the first district
has flipped back and forth between
republicans and democrats rightfully so
because not the same party should have
power all the time
if our voters think that the other party
should be in power they should have the
opportunity to do so
this map is taking that away
we're going to have
a map designed to elect a democrat in
district 2
a republican in district 1 for the next
10 years
why should we even bother to participate
why should we vote
why are we all here at this hearing
today begging you to not do this
it it just makes us feel like this is a
hopeless process
like our elections are predetermined
and that for the next decade we won't
really have a choice we're going to show
up to the polling station we're going to
vote
but this map was drawn for a purpose it
was drawn to create a predetermined
outcome
i'm in the second district
in the past our district has been more
competitive
this map will not
continue that it will make it more
democratic
it will
you know why why even hold a general
election if we know what the outcome is
going to be
it doesn't need to be like this
there is the minorities proposal they've
drawn a map that has made the minimal
changes possible
to make sure the populations are equal
and to keep towns and cities together
we can update our maps to the change of
the population that's what this
redistricting hearing is for
this majority map as everybody has said
has completely moved you know
dozens of towns
can you articulate a reason why
i mean
what is the purpose of completely
redrawing the map other than
the explicit political reasons that
that party chairman that we've heard so
much about has set
i don't know it's
it's quite depressing to think that
that our elections could be
predetermined in this way i think we all
want to participate
we all are asking you to allow us to
keep
the choice that we have
currently we have very competitive maps
we have the ability
to have representatives fight to keep
their jobs they're not assuming that
they're going to win
they're not ignoring constituents
because they know that they don't really
need to work hard to campaign
we should not adopt the majority's map
every single person in this room is
asking you not to do that
please listen to us please
you have the power to prevent this
like other people said you don't need to
adopt the democratic map
there's just no reason to draw such an
absurd gerrymander for for no reason
detached from politics
we're all begging you
please don't do this
thank you
thank you thank you for making the
effort to come down
fred mayer
good evening madam chair members of the
committee thank you very much for this
opportunity
i live in hudson new hampshire i work in
nashua new hampshire
my wife and i have lived in hudson and
worked in nashua for more than the past
three decades
consequently it seems obvious to us
there's a certain community of interest
between those two communities
and therefore i was disappointed to
learn that the majority has put forth a
plan
that would kick my town of hudson into
some new district
along with many other communities into
to
achieve
some result that that
is difficult for me to get my my my head
around and
it
occurred to me that
although
my
personal
little grievance about where my hometown
is is going to wind up if the majority's
maps
were adopted occurred to me that that's
really not the important question for me
to ask
and frankly not the important question
for the representatives to ask
it strikes me that
all the representatives should be going
should be asking themselves
when they go to their communities when
when you talk to your families
when you talk to your neighbors when you
talk to your constituents
do they tell you that what we really
need
is greater polarization
do they tell you that the one thing we
really need is more
partisanship because if they tell you
that what they want
is a plan
that will
be designed to maximize the ideological
distance between the two representatives
that the that this state sends to
congress
well then job well done
but that's not what i think
i don't think that's what i'm hearing in
my community so i ask you is that what
you're hearing in your community
the other important question to ask is
that if you believe
that your party
has
the ideals the values the agenda
shared by the majority of the citizens
of this state then surely what you want
is a
redistricting
process that yields a relatively
even distribution of democratic
democrats and republicans because when
you skew the districts so that one liens
democrat and the other ring leans
republican
what you're doing
is you're giving up
on one of the districts you're writing
it off
if your values are the values of this
state
it would seem to me
that you'd want to go for two
that you'd want to give yourself the
best shot
at electing folks of like mind to both
of our congress congressional districts
and the way to do that
is to give us
fair maps
alternatively
ask yourself whether your party
is so
out of sync with the majority of the
citizens of this state
with the majority of your neighbors that
the only way that you can possibly elect
even one
congress person to the to the united
states congress is to have a skewed map
and if your answer the question is yes
then the question i would leave you with
is under what ethical system can that
possibly be the right thing to do
so i i'll leave you with a request
have a little faith
please have faith
in the citizens of the state of new
hampshire have faith in your friends
your neighbors your constituents have a
little faith in the democratic process
and give us fair maps
thank you very much
sorry i don't have my mic on also signed
up to speak is is roy schweiker from
concord
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee i'm roy schweiker
and
i would like to say that
i don't see the big deal about why it's
bad to move people
from one district to another it makes
the districts better
i think you've heard a lot about how the
majority plan looks like it's
gerrymandered
i'd like you to look at the minority
plan it also looks like it's
gerrymandered
i mean both of them are wacky
we have concord and nashua in the same
district and manchester halfway between
and a different district this is just
outrageous
and if you want to talk about
communities of interest i'd say let's
group the whole southern tier together
we had someone say that it was bad to
put keene pittsburgh and somersworth in
the same district well i say that those
three communities have far more in
common than they have with salem and
nashua
so what i'd like to suggest is you throw
out both of these plans
and you pick land far more rational
you have one district that's essentially
hillsborough and rockingham counties
that's system with the smsa
spreading over from massachusetts it's a
bunch of towns that have common
interests
and it turns out that numerically that's
actually a very good fit
and if you want it to be a better fit
you can shed a few towns
from rockingham county and hillsborough
county into the other district but
you know you can pick towns that may
have more community with that district
so i think that instead of splitting
what is it seven counties you could get
by with splitting zero counties if you
think that number works you could
certainly get by splitting only one
county and most split two counties
and
so that's a very consistent setup and it
works numerically and it works with a
community of interests so i think we
should throw out both these plans for
the congressional districts and do
something to make common sense
and as far as the
county
representative districts
i think i do agree with the people that
once again let's change things if it
makes it better there's no reason that
the city of concord should be sharing
representatives with beau and hopkinton
they should have their own set of
representatives so from that perspective
i would say let's do the concord
representatives like the minority plan
to keep concord together as far as the
rest of the communities
i don't want to speak for them i don't
know if they would like the majority or
minority thing better but certainly
concord should have its own set of
representatives independent of bowen
hopkins thank you
thank you
signed up to speak from new london as
is nancy
nancy you know what i i'm about to do so
remind me please how to pronounce your
last name
nancy moragio from new london
uh a past select board member would
always advise us at meetings
that he wanted to hear compliments and
complaints
compliments first
so i want to start with a compliment
you have changed the process
of redistricting by
honoring people and coming out to the
counties
you coming to them
and allowing the testimony to happen
that way
you've also changed it by what you're
doing tonight
i remember a time when there was a
hearing after the maps were drawn but
the maps were not available to the
public
so we had a hearing nothing to talk
about
so that aspect of the process also
is wonderful that you've done
and i hope both of those processes
continue in the future
because it honors the voters and it
honors your listening
a complaint is that
we don't know the standards you all used
we don't know if democrats and
republicans use the same ones
we don't know if the standards across
the various kinds of maps are the same
and it would be useful to know those
standards
a compliment
you know the fair max
maps coalition of four
non-partisan organizations
has done a great deal of work
and we thank you for paying attention to
that work
we had experts drawing maps
you paid attention to those
we had a new category of standard
communities of interest
which provided a huge amount of
insight in fact they did surveys 60
questions i think on the surveys of many
communities
to unearth
various communities of interest i want
to use as an example um
new london my town and newbury my former
town
for example the survey on earth that
they share assessors
well that matters
it also shows us how to look at the maps
and i would recommend for new london
that you use
the majority map
the minority map puts new london with
danbury
thinking of communities of interest
danbury is in a different regional
planning commission
it's in the newfound school district
new london is in the kirsaj district
things like that matter when you have a
representative trying to look at the
range of the communities they work with
newberry who we've been with for 10
years
has the same kind of problem on the
minority map
it puts us back with henniker
you've heard my anecdote before
when we were put with henniker the first
time
one of the people running for office in
henniker happened to come
to the town office and library the same
time i was there
and she said
oh what a lovely town i've never been
here before
that is not the kind of representation
you want
i would also like to share that the
select boards of of new london and
newbury both met on monday
agreeing um to send you official letters
asking that you keep that district
together
and you will see that fairmap's
standard of communities of interest is
really important
a negative
has to be
and i say this is a new hampshire native
the
congressional district
that was drawn by the majority
will probably go down in textbooks if
you pass it as one of the worst examples
of gerrymandering ever
i don't want to see that as a new
hampshire native please reconsider thank
you
thank you
richard gelinas from nashua
madam chair members of the committee
thank you for your efforts and for this
opportunity
pretty much everybody that's gone before
me has said what i wanted to say i
am here to speak in opposition of
uh
uncompetitive districts
and what we see here is uncompetitive
districts
i think we know that democracy is
fragile and this map would be unhelpful
in strengthening it
electing representatives from the
margins will only further divide our
state and our country
and
some examples of people that have been
elected from uncompetitive districts
alexandria ocasio-cortez
marjorie taylor green
rashida talib
jim jordan ayanna presley
and matt goetz
so that's something to think about uh
when you sit down to
hopefully reevaluate re-evaluate this
but again everybody else has said
said what i came here to say so i'm not
going to belabor the point
thank you
marie morgan from goffstown
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you tonight
thank you for serving as state reps
thank you for
serving in this special committee
as this gentleman said
the people who've already spoken i agree
with uh
pretty much that they were much more
eloquent than i am
and i appreciate that
i spoke to you
or some of you
at the goffstown high school
was that in october
and um
some of you
were there some of you weren't
were here i think all of you were here
yesterday as i was
and there were over 35 people i think
who spoke
uh several of you took me uh
notes
several of you had the maps out and when
people talked about
uh the different towns and they didn't
seem to make sense or have communities
of interest i saw several of you write
that down
several of you said
from was it 10 to 12 or 12 30 didn't
take a break
i noticed a few of you took more than
one break
i noticed some of you didn't take
any minutes or notes
i noticed some of you didn't even have
papers in front of you
so it was interesting
but back to uh the meeting at in
goffstown high school
at that time i gave you
[Music]
a
outline
of all the towns in hillsboro and i had
written down their population
and at the time i had had said that gee
so many of these little towns were
getting so many
reps
and i suggested maybe you could look
into that
uh because
i guess the ideal
the ideal population is 3444
people for for one rep
and i have some copies
and i apologize there were a few errors
on the
the list i
provided you back in goffstown
but briefly
windsor
has a population of 262 people
with the republican and majority map
they are assigned three reps
sharon population 359
assigned two reps
temple 1382 residents assigned four reps
mason
1448 people assigned six reps
bennington 1500 people assigned three
but then greenfield
1716 people assigned only one
daring
1904 people assigned one
greenville those were the lucky people
somebody wanted to start a game here
greenville has population of 1974.
they're given six
state reps
but then antrim has a 200 2651
they're assigned three reps
i i won't stand here all night you all
got things to do
in manchester i'll just go down to
manchester
um
they are
allowed
33.58
reps and the republicans have said well
32 should be enough for them
and put
give them eight floatarials within
manchester which i don't understand
as many of the people have said here
tonight many of the people who said
yesterday
and all the people who voted for an
independent redistricting commission
we want fair maps
we'd like to know how you came up with
those maps
even with this committee uh when i was
at the meeting last week
one of you
put out that u.s congressional map
and said i did this i i figured this out
i figured this out for 15 minutes this
person said that they did this map
and then all of a sudden the person
changed said the committee did the map
so it's kind of interesting why all of a
sudden one person did the map then the
committee did the map
representative mcguire she submitted
maps to the public week for the rest of
you did
what's the process
you know did one of you do a map for a
county
and then the others just accept it
i'm not even sure on the dem side of how
it was done
um
but you only have what next week to the
18th tomorrow is a holiday you have the
weekend so within four or five days
you're all going to say yes or no
as many of the people have said
go back work together
i know those deviations are a pain in
the neck i've been trying to figure out
how to do deviations for the last couple
of days i think i finally figured it out
but i don't even understand why
you look at the deviations and they're
1.15 well so what the town should have
its own rep
but it doesn't but yet it's got a good
deviation
it's it's crazy
and i sympathize with you to a point
but but i just hope that you um
will take the time to give us fair maps
thank you again for all your time
to to work on this committee
thank you
rebecca hutchinson
uh thank you madam chairman and
committee i i will be quick my name is
rebecca hutchinson i'm from deerfield
and i would like to speak to the issue
of the state rep districts and
particularly in rockingham county and i
hope i'm going to share a little detail
about what it means
for those of us who are in small towns
to have to share
our reps with other towns
specifically i think both maps actually
put deerfield
uh in some kinds of combinations with
five other towns deerfield candy and
nottingham
uh northwood and auburn
and i just would like to tell you that
in deerfield
over a hundred residents
signed a letter requesting our board of
selectmen
to advocate on our behalf to get our own
state rep
during this process
they did that
the five member date reps
unanimously supported the
effort
or the request that we had our own
state rep
i would i'd also like to tell you that
the
five members of our board are
republicans and independents there isn't
a democrat among them
and i want to share with you that
um
those hundred people in our town who
requested that we
advocate strongly for our own state rep
the breakdown of those hundred people
was about 35 percent republican 33
independent and about 31 32 percent
democrat which
pretty accurately reflects
the party affiliation in here
so my point that i want to make is that
there were more republicans
requesting our own state rep than the
other parties so
the question is why is there such a
bipartisan call
for deerfield to have its own state rep
as we did
before 2002
deerfield is in two districts now i
think with the new ones it would also be
in two districts but i want to focus
on our experience with one of the
districts
we are in a town we are in a three-town
district
that elects
three state reps
so in
none of the three people who won
a district-wide seat
actually came in first
in their own town
two of them were from deerfield
one was from nottingham
and none of them won in their own town
to make it worse
one of those who won district-wide
came in fourth
in our town
they weren't even in the top three
so
what is happening is people are getting
elected by the other
towns 2020 it was a little bit better
slightly
the individual who won in deerfield
also won
statewide
so
we can say yeah that's
at least we are electing
someone we know and they and they won in
the state
but again
the same individual
from our town who came in fourth
in 2018 in our town also came in fourth
in our town
but was elected
by the district
so what is happening
is people
are getting elected
in by the other tenants
so it's not only that we don't get
uh to vote for a single representative
to represent deerfield it's actually
worse than that
because
we
people that the district elects people
that we know very well
and don't and reject time and time again
literally
we have a rep
who has run for selectmen five times in
our town
and been rejected every time
we also have a rep who's run for school
board
i've actually lost count it's either
four or five times
and is always defeated
but they go to these multi-town
districts
and they get elected
it's really frustrating
i believe i'm correct that both
the majority and the minority maps
have five towns
in our area and again i repeat them
they're deerfield candy and nottingham
northwood and
auburn and i believe both of your maps
give us seven reps
each of those towns
is large enough to have its own state
rep
so you could
give
five reps to the five towns and do two
for materials and have the same number
but then we would actually have an
opportunity
to elect people who represent us
we are tired
of rejecting people
because we know them well
and then have them elected by the other
tents
now i suspect this happens in other
districts as well
um i don't know that for sure but i i
suspect that what does
and it doesn't have to be
so i would ask you again
to look at that concept of gathering
everybody who's possibly you know who's
got the right number of population their
own district and start from there thank
you
thank you
i have kim and harold frost signed up
from aetna
hi i'm kim frost and i live in netan new
hampshire i'm a member of the league of
women voters of new hampshire and a
member of the new hampshire mapathon's
technical team
but the following testimony is my own
as you know the mapathon team has spent
the last several months collecting data
on communities of interest developing
criteria for evaluating maps and
drafting fair maps to share with the
public and with your committee
we believe that democracy depends upon a
a fair and open open redistricting
process and that voters should choose
their own representatives rather than
representatives choosing their voters
i attended the hearing last week when
republicans and democrats on the
committee shared their redistricting
proposals for new hampshire's two
congressional seats
representative ross berry explained that
the rationale for the gop map was to
unite the communities in the southern
tier
in particular the towns of hudson
windham litchfield pelham salem and
atkinson
into one congressional district
he explained that the proposed map was
necessary in order to do this
well this is of course a community of
interest we collected data on
communities of interest from over 200
participants and this particular coi was
not mentioned by anybody
participants in our nonpartisan process
identified the following cio cois listed
an order of priority
shared high school saus
shared water and sanitation services
shared police and fire services
shared public health regions communities
that high in social vulnerability as
identified by by new hampshire dhhs and
shared regional planning commissions
it turns out that representative barry's
coi crosses boundaries for the counties
in the center at the southern tier
and for the public health region and
regional planning commission cois
it also does not have significant shared
high school saus water and sanitation
services police and fire services or
communities higher high in social
vulnerability that appear to connect the
whole all of those towns into a larger
community
as a result we had not previously taken
representative various coi into account
in our own analyses
being the dedicated data geeks that we
are however several members of our team
immediately set to work to see if
representative barry's coi could be
combined with these other cois to create
a map that responded to this hitherto
unknown coi and still respect the others
and all of the other important
redistricting concerns such as low
deviation compactness competitiveness
splitting and preservation of the core
of of prior districts
five of us spent about 15 minutes each
creating alternative maps in dave's
redistricting software
each of us generated a map that
respected this new cli and had lower
deviation was more compact and
competitive split fewer counties and
fewer other communities of interest and
preserved more of the core of the prior
districts
i've attached these maps and their
associated analyses to my testimony and
i'll share that with you afterwards
if communities of interest are really
important to the new hampshire
redistricting committee i would re
respectfully suggest that they take
another look at the original mapathon
proposal
um
which which does a better job of
combining those communities of interest
or at alternative number one in the
testimony that i'm going to share with
you both of which do a much better job
with cois than the republican proposal
i noticed however that the
gop's proposed map is eerily similar to
the gerrymandered map published by 538
in january of 2018.
may i point out that the proposed map is
in fact the ideal gerrymandering
mandarin by either the republican
republicans or the democrats
i've also attached some analyses here by
538 that show that the current new
hampshire congressional districts are
highly competitive and proportionately
partisan and that gerrymandered maps
will result in two districts where the
other party has less than a one in six
chance of winning an election
of course by this analysis if you
believe in competitive districts the
democrats proposal is a clear winner
as you all know and as you've heard here
before heavily heavily gerrymandered
maps such as the ones proposed by the
republicans on this committee will
create more extreme candidates for both
parties and drive us further apart
this is a terrible plan for the people
of new hampshire
thank you
harold frost
madam chairman
madam chairman committee
um thank you for the opportunity to
speak
i'm not sure i have any eloquence to
change anybody's mind
particularly at this late hour
but i wanted to go on record with my
opinion
and i'd like to put it like this
back in my high school american history
which is getting to be some time ago
the textbook explained to us how the
politicians
in massachusetts the state to our south
uh created uh sort of a
slimy beast
looked like a salamander
and they called it a gerrymander
now this was not written up as an
example of good governance
it was
the sort of thing that
people in new hampshire generally look
down upon because
they expect their local government to be
honest and competent
rightly so
and
imagine my surprise then to wake up one
morning recently
and see in my
morning newspaper
that the gerrymandered beast had
crawled up the merrimack river valley
and was sitting in the middle
of new hampshire
so let me explain it is your job as a
committee
to beat back the gerrymandered beast
thank you
christine fergierto
hi there
good evening madam chairwoman and
committee members
my name is christine fajardo
thank you for the opportunity to take
part in this important discussion and i
appreciate that following the previous
round of public hearings were here
tonight
and able to respond to actual maps which
you did make public
many people have described how unfair
maps impact cities towns and
constituents on an individual basis and
there are certainly no shortage of
details to remark upon
but i'm going to zoom out a little bit
and look at this for more of a macro
view and try to help answer the question
of
what the big picture impacts might be
keeping our districts fair doesn't just
have implications at the city town and
regional level it also stands to have
major implications for new hampshire at
the national level
unfair districts will damage new
hampshire's reputation as a leader and
responsible steward of our nation's
democracy
our reputation as a small but mighty
state with the ability to drive
democratic outcomes through our first in
the nation primary
or unpredictably award our key electoral
votes because of our fiercely
independent voters
will be called into question
our status as leaders on the national
stage for how democracy could and should
function
will be irreparably tarnished
to begin with new hampshire will become
predictable
candidates will no longer venture over
the line into other parties territories
robbing granite staters of our
long-standing tradition of up close and
personal retail politics
we'll no longer have the benefit of
meeting candidates on our doorsteps
being courted as though our single vote
could make all the difference
instead we'll be seen as one of two
monoliths
robbed of our individual individuality
and independence
new hampshire will no longer be the
will no longer be leading the
conversation and instead will be pushed
off to the margins
new hampshire's credibility will be
permanently damaged instead of making
national headlines for again our small
but mighty state and all that we deliver
for this country and its democracy we're
now making national headlines for our
blatant flouting of it
some have argued that redistricting is
i'm sorry some have argued that
redrawing district lines is an
inherently political process
and therefore that might justify
diluting voices of voters but this isn't
passing the smell test beyond new
hampshire's borders
particularly in states like nevada and
south carolina who already have concerns
about new hampshire's outsized impacts
on our national on the national stage
this would be a boon to their arguments
and advantage them in their efforts to
override us
most critically new hampshire could
become irrelevant
we won't have a leg to stand on when we
boast about our independence
our status as a swing state will be
replaced with a status that we are
immovable
a heavy anchor lodged in our own granite
bedrock
we know the possibility of the
long-standing effects of these maps
we're aware of the disregard for
historical presidents precedents
we expected a political battle but are
we really prepared to sacrifice
everything that's important to us
thank you
patrick
eggleston
patrick eggleston from amherst new
hampshire
i just want to briefly draw your
attention to an article that was
published november 2018 in scientific
can you
yeah you need to speak a little more
okay thank you okay
um drawing your attention to an article
published in scientific american
november
title mathematicians are developing
forensics
to identify political maps that
disenfranchise voters
and then the
title was geometry versus gerrymandering
the article
was trying to point out
the difficulty of spotting
gerrymandering that's
at least fairly sophisticated
and it went on to talk about some of the
ways that were then being considered to
really be able to get a hold of
good measures of it
since then
there have been
[Music]
computer programs developed
to draw these maps and
roughly speaking they're of two types
one is that
is trying to do german mandarin but make
it look like it's not
so it looks sort of respectable
and the
are taking the course
of really trying to make it
so that it is not gerrymandered
um
texas for example
has used the one
that
attempts to make it sort of look
respectable but is a horrible example of
gerrymandering
and
i
am thinking that we should be trying
to use one
that really avoids gerrymandering
and many of the speakers i think have
spoken very well
about why
this is important
it's important that we have
[Music]
people that have to go into their
district
and
appeal
somewhat to both democrats republicans
independents
that would be a very good
low lower case d
democratic
system
and it might cut down some of the anger
that we keep seeing in some places i
mean
it's just unspeakable
what some
people that have been elected are saying
and
it's because they feel
that theirs is a safe position and they
can say what they want
and they can still get elected
so
i think we need to think carefully about
getting something that is seriously not
gerrymandering for all the reasons that
i've said and for reasons that were said
even better by some of the former
speakers thank you
thank you
um
i've been handed three blue sheets with
names of people who signed up to speak
and i and i've called on everyone who
has signed up to speak i want to thank
everybody sitting here up i'm getting
handed another one thank you
steven meer
we wouldn't have forgotten you
madam chair thank you so much members of
the committee
um
thank you for the opportunity to give
testimony my name is stephen minow i'm a
resident of manchester ward 3
and i am representing myself and i am
not affiliated with any other
organization
i'm not someone who normally speaks out
at these meetings or weighs in on
political matters
i but i felt compelled to come here
before this committee as someone who has
worked in new hampshire government at
both the regional and the county level
and because i love this state and the
ideas that it purports to stand for
my background is in land use planning
and economic development i have a
master's degree in regional planning
with
a focus on gis systems mapping and
cartography
and i moved into the state in 2016 to
work at the planner for the regional
planning commissions
i have lived and worked in both
congressional districts and several
state house districts and i'm currently
a homeowner
and i understand both from the
governmental and a personal perspective
the importance of fair maps that reflect
the unique regions of the state and
really honor the underlying political
boundaries like school districts like
regional planning commissions like sewer
and water district
like public health regions
and in this proposed map the seacoast is
unnecessarily divided
lines go which unnecessarily separate
counties and as a manchester resident
the state house map will reduce our
representation even though our
population has grown
in the 2010 map manchester had 33 seats
and the city population has since grown
but under the current republican plan it
only gets 32 seats
these maps dilute the power of region of
regions and force unnecessary changes
upon local municipalities who already
have a limited capacity and now we'll
have to explain to voters they're in a
completely different congressional
district that their state
representatives have completely changed
i'm disappointed in the republican
proposed congressional map will impose
these burdens
and not for reasons of compactness
geographic similarities or political his
um or historical boundaries
but for political considerations
um every voice should be heard and every
vote should be carried the same way
by drawing maps to favor one political
party politicians are rigging the
process of representation and denying
voters their fair share i urge this
committee and the house to reject this
republican version of the map thank you
for your time
thank you and thank you for coming
is there anybody else who wants to speak
representative you're standing why don't
you come on now
i'll defer to this
thank you madam chair
for the record peter schmidt
representing
district 19 which is stratford
uh dover awards one and two
so i'll be brief
we've heard a lot of
extraordinary
wisdom tonight
i hope that the majority
has listened carefully
because like the great majority perhaps
everyone i couldn't quite understand the
point of view of the gentleman who spoke
a little while ago
but
like like the great majority tonight i
reject the majorities proposed maps
i consider the
congressional map to be
literally odious
and villainous
we should not go there
as far as the
state rep maps
many of them are
defective and deficient
they are
simply
do not represent good mechanical
treatment
of
the state and i've been in the house now
for 19 years i've seen
the
young lady who ran out here
out the door from deerfield who gave you
a wonderful analysis of the
very deleterious effects
of
the
planned in existing maps
of
her district in deerfield and the
surrounding towns
pleased
you've heard not only eloquence
and also
a very thorough analysis of some
speakers
please
don't just make this a party line vote
if that's what it's going to be
it demonstrates that this is not a good
arrangement either at the congressional
level or at the state level please we
can do better than this
don't give us
a partisan vote
thank you
thank you representative
sir you had your hand up also
good evening thank you for the
opportunity um and let me say i
appreciate all the time that all the
committee members have put into this i
spent some time today reading uh the
comments from the various meetings i
know so many of you put have put in so
much sir thank you could we just have
your name for the record my name is
corey bellabrow i live here in concord i
was admitted to practice law here in
1981 and have done so for the most part
of these 40 years consistently
and
i just have a couple of comments number
one this meeting started with the pledge
of allegiance which ends with injustice
for all
in my opinion it is not justice for all
to shift
365 000 people's voting um from one
district to another or from each
district uh half of those people from
one to another
for a reason i'm not sure of
other than for politics
so that's my first comment the second
comment i have is that
if you try to move
365 000 new hampshire citizens
for any other reason any other project
for a waterway for a highway for a
utility
i think you'd have a revolution on your
hands instead you've gotten very cordial
citizens making excellent comments
somewhat repetitive but excellent um
very civilly and i think people who are
not
i've i've been on my feet all my life as
a lawyer uh these people have done an
excellent job i think that guy in the
far right your far right is a ringer he
did a really excellent job
but i have to tell you i mean the
citizens have appeared in front of you
they've given you their frank opinions i
read most of the written comments i
skimmed a bunch of them and they seem to
be unanimously in favor
we call that the overwhelming weight of
the evidence as justice lynn as i know
him
would tell you
i understand in in a representative
system you are free to vote as you would
but the overwhelming weight of the
evidence says you should reject the
majority plan
that doesn't mean you should accept the
minority plan but it does mean you
should not
vote for the majority plan
thank you all
thank you
yes sir i see a hand
would you like to speak
sure come on down
my name is kevin st james and i'm with
the town of kingston i want to thank you
madam chair and every other member
honorable member of this committee
you heard a lot of people speak today
i'm sure you've listened to it all i
hope you received the message i just
want to speak specifically to rockingham
county and the redistricting map to
rockingham county
though all the towns have grown
proportionally they have been equal
across
i would ask you keep rockingham county
the way it is
just as as it has been for the last 10
years it is equal across i've been a
commissioner for six years uh a former
commissioner for six years in rockingham
county
and the other issue that happens if you
do redistrict the whole county is how do
you
give you up the seat of four year terms
so if you keep it the same it goes on
the same and it's been equal
representation on both sides the proud
republican i would ask you again keep it
the same thank you for your time have a
good evening thank you for coming
is there anybody else who'd like to
speak tonight
um mr farnam you were our first speaker
does that mean i need to end all my
meetings with the first speaker in the
future if we if we go forward with this
i think for 30 seconds we can have mr
farnham come back to the mic
uh thank you for your time
i'd just like to comment on the carroll
county map
for redistricting of the house seats
um i look across it and i see violations
uh on this
great presentation by the mapathon
people and it goes democrats have three
violations republicans have four
mapathon under a 15 percent
deviation
has one
and their regular map has three
i would like to enter this
into the record and say that maybe the
deviation
is the problem because i think all towns
that deserve should have their own
representation thank you thank you
we've already got it you don't need to
oh it was thank you we'll have it copied
and scanned to everybody then so anybody
else here would like to speak tonight
i want to thank everybody for coming
um
and commenting on these maps the work of
the committee continues the work on the
maps will continue this is a bill just
like any other house process
it will come out of our committee go to
the senate the senate has certain maps
that they're working on will come back
to us
and will eventually go to vote
i expect in january of next year so that
we're
in the throes of the legislative process
of getting a bill out and i want to
thank you all for coming tonight for
this public information session and
speaking to us on it and travel safely
home good night
[Applause]
i saw you taking it off